qui sont les politiques et les citoyens
qui se permettent de porter un avis sur
qui doit être à la télé ou pas
simplement parce qu'ils sont pas
d'accord quelque part le problème c'est
pas qu'ils sont pas ce qu'est la justice
qui régule ça il ya le csa c'est à la
justice de votre en garde le ce soit
voilà mais y'avait qu'à la justice s'il
déborde hills a déjà été saisi il a été
condamné et c'est le rôle de la justice
et du csa mais c'est pas le rôle est
encore bien a dit fermement l asus eee
mais le csa c'est ok deux poids deux
mesures peut-être lancé rien mais en
tant qu en tout cas ce n'est pas aux
citoyens de décider d'interdire
quelqu'un d'antenne et j'étais encore
plus choquée par les marques qui on a
arrêté de faire de la publicité pendant
la plage horaire d'eric zemmour alors
servir saifullah mais c'est très grave
avarie pourra pourtant ces matières ou
quoi c'est vrai que je dis aux
téléspectateurs il n'y a pas de pub
pendant l'émission directement puisque
les marques se sont retirés 1c
sacristine n'ont même pas c'est une
décision de la mairie se lâcher de pub
on me servir dans le vent et on va voir
mais problème la partie ça permet
d'avoir plus long des âmes des malades a
censuré que des marques quand même que
je ne serai pas celle où t'es là qui
doit faire la politique et du toit d'une
chaîne c'est quand même très grave et
sacs et jean-charles dit à l'ats le
directeur des beaux quartiers je regarde
l'histoire et marc ferrero c'est tout le
groupe fait après l'histoire et marchica
n'a je suis pas d'accord là dessus
ferrero et font ce qu'ils veulent s'il
va bien sûr communiqué main sur une
émission elle est maigre mais précieux
qui met l'argent si j'ai pas envie de
communiquer sur l'émission d'eric
zemmour est reçu et les bien sûr ils
sont avec l'ambassadeur actuellement
pardon c'est patrice
ces mois là bas c'est pas la peine
d'être naïf si on interdisait eric
zemmour d'antenne évidemment que
maintenant avec les réseaux sociaux avec
les nouvelles télés les chaînes tout le
monde diffuse des messages ça voudrait
dire qu'on laisserait diffuser n'importe
quel message sans aucun contrôle
au moins sur les chaînes de télé il y a
effectivement de la production il y à un
contrôle et c'est le seul moyen
effectivement d'équilibrer la forme est
sûre et personne n'a jamais été interdit
d'antenne jackson alors karim zéribi
vous êtes en immouni non je suis pas ni
oui ni l'argent perdre et si je peux
m'expliquer des attentivement les
tenants de didon moi je trouve je suis
toujours stupéfait de voir cette
approche jaïdi on peut à géométrie
balade de la liberté d'expression dans
notre ami est très bien c'est
extraordinaire a les mêmes vont dire
c'était scandaleux si on habitait
dieudonné et les mêmes bruits expliquer
mais attention la liberté d'expression
mais il faut quand même on peut pas
brimer eric zemmour de liberté
d'expression donc c'est normal qu'on
limite
moi vous savez j'ai pas d'approché à
géométrie variable si j'ai mis 2 que le
carton comme ça faut-il interdire
d'antenne eric zemmour d'antenne nom eût
pu donner une émission non plus je ne
suis pas pour qu'on lui donne une
émission en revanche je suis pas pour
qu'on le bat nice des médias mais je
n'étais pas pour qu'on bannisse des
médias dieudonné donc je suis cohérent
même si je ne suis pas d'accord avec ces
gens là comme bol vert
je me battrai jusqu'à la mort pour
qu'ils puissent s'exprimer pourquoi
cette fois lorsque je pense qu'à dresser
du mal à garder le mec qui me dit j'ai
de l'amitié
mais c'est un gros raciste donc bah si
tu dois le multipoint raciste moi je
sais pas ce que tu
au contraire j'ai été clair le connaître
il met parasols et on est ce alors c'est
quelqu'un si j'ai bien poursuivre
quelqu'un qui n'est pas raciste qui
comparé l'islam au nazisme quelqu'un qui
n'est pas raciste qui va expliquer que
pétain a sauvé des juifs alors qu'il en
a déporté de cake des femmes des enfants
de venir nous battre quelqu'un qui n'est
pas raciste qui explique effectué ne se
rendent pas pour mes trains kg m'a donc
que s'il avait été dit jo comme bugeaud
donc quand c'est parce que ça fait
partie des valeurs françaises donc ils
auraient tué des gens comme alban n'a vu
là on a vu l'extrait de marée humaine
des juges
donc moi je vais te dire ce déversoir de
haine c'est insupportable
c'était supportable et ce qui
m'insupporte d'autant plus c'est
effectivement le fait que je considère
aujourd'hui qu'il n'a pas d'adversité
en réalité vous iriez vous vous auriez
moi j'irai parce que je considère
effectivement qu'à un moment donné des
idées à apporter dès aujourd'hui à
rajouter car ici pardonne moi je ne suis
pas pour interdire la radio je ne suis
pas pour qu'on donne une l'émission est
ce que ça peut être clair quand on est
petit on s'organise ça fait longtemps
qu'il est moi les débats contre eric
zemmour je vais d'abord je l' ai déjà
fait donc sur le plateau de chez news il
ya quatre mois de qui les thèmes
inhabituels va lever ces conditions il
était invité d'un punch and donc en tant
qu'invité c'était pas son émission le
fait qu'on lui donne une émission jetons
qu'on donne une tribune
somavia et c'est pas une émission 1000
et là tous les jours j'en ai me suis
stationné s'agit pas là tous les jours
je suis candidat c'est dire des jeux car
l'impression qu'on est conscient à la
mène oui mais pas sur tous les toits de
finition à son habitude qui dit les
cochonneries malaise
si après on va arrêter l'hypocrisie la
langue et la vérité aussi si on arrête
l'hypocrisie
oui à la tradition rock résidents c'est
votre émission mais il est là si les
journaux puis s'il n'est pas eric
zemmour c'est une émission est pas
d'émission su autour d'eric zemmour et
vous mine de rien oui mais c'est de
soleil ça tous les jours mais c'est pas
son émission
oui parce que s'il n'y avait pas eu ces
mots une émission ah ben moi j'étais ici
à moi ma fierté sûreté pmp qui aurait
pas une démission qui avait pas eu ces
mots mais c'est les stations d'émission
parce qu'il aurait pu la voir lui par
exemple son émission oui à lui tout seul
il n'y a pas sonné la balle et mais je
suis un journaliste qu'il aurait pu en
faire son émission il ne l'a pas ouais
moi je voudrais expliquer je voudrais
poser une question qu'on me pose jamais
pourquoi est ce que zemmour ça marche
pourquoi les gens regardent zemmour
pourquoi les gens achètent parce qu'il
avec naulleau mais ce n'est pas la
partie sans contrat qui sont sourds
s'est néanmoins bien de l'explication
qu'il paraît que tu as chaud lui le
connaissez non c'est que pendant des
années 90 pour cent des médias ont
expliqué à la population française que
ce qu'ils voyaient ils ne le voyais pas
que ce qu'ils vivaient ils ne le vivais
pas zemmour est arrivé il a commencé à
expliquer et maintenant quand vous
voulez l'interdire d'antenne les gens se
disent ah c'est un des seuls qui nous
représente
à tort ou à raison avec les conneries
que peut dire zemmour et que je dénonce
en privé ou public
mais il est représentative de certaines
personnes qui ont l'impression qu'on ne
prend pas en compte qu'ils sont pas
invités non c'est un homme qu'il
n'existe
il n'existe pas et que le reste les
médias faisaient comme si le negresco